leute diese cutler film geschnitten die
steine also leute da ist die
polizeistation und ich habe genau davor
falsch gefragt hey was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt gut wir haben dienstag oder
mittwoch keine ahnung also ohne dieses
video online komplett kamerateams was
soll das denn
und hier auch das sieht gar nicht gut
aus sieht gar nicht gut aus
egal jetzt wahrscheinlich schon gelesen
ich hab das irgendwann letztlich wieder
in den kommentaren gefunden und zwar
machen wir heute 24 stunden nur
autobahnraststätte sowas habe ich noch
nirgendwo gesehen und ich bin wirklich
gespannt also ich bin sehr gespannt ich
habe gerade hier schon gefrühstückt
werden mittlerweile auch schon 10 uhr 30
oder sogar 11 uhr das ding ist also ich
fand dass kinder heute an weil ich genau
wie auch nach köln fahren da komme ich
an genug rastplätzen vorbei ich wollte
eigentlich schon früher bewusst von
anderen direkt mit frühstück anfangen
habe ich da nicht geschafft ist aber an
sich auch kein problem ich mein anfang
haben mit dem mittagessen ich habe mir
gerade hier mal die website rausgesucht
und ja wenn man sich das hier so
anschaut
also ich würde sagen wir fahren jetzt
mal los dann erklärte rest von der
challenge und wir sehen uns im auto
bis gleich so weiter aufgeht wichtig was
ich noch sagen wollte also mit
autobahnraststätte meine ich natürlich
dieser ganz typischen ich weiß nicht so
was nennt sich dass der glaube ich bis
jetzt immer wenn ich auf der
autobahnraststätte war um irgendwas zu
essen habe ich mir meistens
anderen raster auf jeden fall was los
ist
was ich noch sagen wollte ganz wichtig
also ich meine halte dieses restaurants
ich glaube die sind zwar extrem teil ich
habe da vorher wirklich noch nie
gegessen sonst hätte ich mir irgendwas
an der autobahn hole ist es halt
meistens mal irgendwie schnellenberger
oder so ich meine mich da nicht rein
setzt mich entspannt hin und es
irgendwie so ein schnitzel für 17 euro
aber ich habe mich wirklich noch nie mit
beschäftigt was ist ja alles gibt
deswegen will ich sage ich mal auf die
challenge und nachschauen metalist wird
was man also kriegt ich hoffe ihr freut
euch und wir fangen jetzt weiter so
aufgetankt weiter geht hatte ich bin
gerade mal zehn minuten unterwegs direkt
wirklich ein heftiger staubig weiß nicht
ob ein unfall passiert ist oder so aber
ja schon vom verein muss dazu sagen
normalerweise ist hier nie staub so
leute was platz nummer 1 ich bin
angekommen
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was ich dazu
essen findet man muss aber auch sagen
das wird heute ist wirklich extrem
heftig also es sind bestimmt 15 grad
oder nicht sogar noch wärmer also gibt
es auf jeden fall auch im burger king
aber wir gehen zu sehr weiß wie auch
immer das heißt wenn die kommentare so
weit also ich muss sagen ich saß noch
nie kommt das erst mal an ich sage es
noch nie irgendwie draußen bei so einer
raststätte an der autobahn und hat
gegessen
ich habe mir jetzt hier mal spaghetti
geholt
hat mich insgesamt mit dieser
apfelschorle hier zehn euro gekostet ist
ja an sich sogar ok brot frisch gemacht
deswegen ich fühle mich da gar nicht
beschweren ich hätte gedacht das wär
teurer
wir probieren das jetzt mal sie da waren
sich ganz gut aus wir haben eigentlich
gerade genau das mittagsgeschäft wie ist
aber niemand außer ich also irgendwie
muss das hier was heißen also ich muss
sagen es schmeckt jetzt nicht umwerfen
aber ist voll okay also schmeckt wie zu
hause eigentlich
so leute also aufgegessen ich habe mich
eigentlich richtig gefreut
oder ich bin richtig stolz auf mich weil
da waren bestimmt so 20 leute in diesem
restaurant und an hamburger gegessen
außer ich war heiß und geil
mir ist aufgefallen ich habe es gerade
noch vergessen das menü abzufilmen weil
das ist ja mal ganz interessant nur ich
will mich dann auch nicht immer so keine
trend dahin scheint das einfach filmen
weil viele wollen das nicht ich hatte
irgendwie da immer so ein schnitzel in
erinnerung für 17 euro und das habe ich
jetzt nicht gesehen kann auch sein dass
sie die preise herunter gestuft haben
ich frage mich um ehrlich zu sein
sowieso wer da mal ist weil keine ahnung
so umgehauen hat es mich jetzt nicht
geschmacklich es war okay gut das ist
hier eine autobahnraststätte aber man
muss sagen beim italiener kommt mit dem
gleichen hin und es schmeckt fünfmal so
gut aber gut wir fahren jetzt weiter und
wir sehen uns dann in köln
soweit ich bin mittlerweile wieder in
köln und hab ja also ich muss mal kurz
zur sache klarstellen
einige von euch denken wahrscheinlich
schon dass ich ein bisschen dumm bin
zumindest die die sich auskennen
ich bin ja die ganze zeit also ich
dachte das wirklich das war mein bild
sagen wir mal so von autobahnraststätten
das ist halt an fast jeder
autobahnraststätte einmal irgendwie
burger king mcdonalds cathy was auch
immer gibt und sehr ways gibt's hier
auch aber ich habe gedacht diese
restaurants die dann das sind die heißen
serways sehr weil ich weiß immer noch
nicht wie man das ausspricht
das ist aber wohl nicht so es gibt so
ein unternehmen das heißt tank & rast
kennt ihr vielleicht und den gehören
diese ganzen rastplätze und die
rastplätze nennen sich surveys
vielleicht heißt es ja auch auf deutsch
einfach rastplatz also ich bin wirklich
ein bisschen verwirrt weil man findet
auch keine übersetzung von serways ich
hätte das gedacht das kommt aus einer
amerikanischen heißt rastplatz
vielleicht so habe ich vorher noch nie
gehört keine ahnung also kurz
zusammengefasst segways ist so der
begriff für eine autobahnraststätte und
unter diesem surveys liegen dann alle
möglichen restaurant toilette
möglichkeit cafés ja genau hier haben
wie zum beispiel die website da war ich
ja schon drauf und hier sind einige
sachen aufgelistet die die halt zu haben
ich war eben weil diese moskitos essen
und da dachte ich halte das ding heißt
airways ich weiß nicht ob ich der
einzige bin der so gedacht hat
vielleicht ihr ja auch zum teil schreibt
es gerne in die kommentare ist aber
scheißegal wir fahren jetzt weiter zum
nächsten star weiß weil wir damals 18
uhr 30 und mal schauen was da so gibt
hard rain
also leute auf geht es zum nächsten
rastplatz was ich noch sagen wollte also
ich habe mich mal informiert ob man
vielleicht
eine speisekarte findet die werden halt
alle so individuell betrieben von
verschiedenen personen und da gibt es
über was anderes also irgendwie gibt es
nicht so ein typisches restaurant an der
raststätte wollt die speisepläne
komplett gleich sind außerhalb so fast
flugzeugs aber das wollen wir ja nicht
jetzt ist mir aufgefallen jacke wäre
nicht schlecht aber habe ich vergessen
kein problem mehr ist ein bisschen
wärmer geworden ich habe echt hunger
dann sind auch da ich stehe direkt davor
praktisch ich muss aber sagen ich habe
absolut den überblick verloren
wir haben jetzt auf dieser seite
irgendwie wohl keines herr ways sondern
segafredo raststätten service also eine
autobahn hat er aber zwei richtung und
auf der anderen seite ist auch den rest
muss und da ist er ist hier ein das
essen sieht so aus von hier ja ich bin
mal gespannt was da gibt und wie teuer
das ist
[Musik]
der jetzt bestand also leute das hier
schmeckt ganz gut dass hier nicht so ein
bisschen wie im fußballstadion leute
diese kartoffeln
die schmecken wie steine ich fühle mich
euch nicht aufgegessen oder so halbwegs
aufgegessen hinter mir haben wir nochmal
das restaurant
also ich muss auf jeden fall sagen ich
habe wirklich selten so schlecht
gegessen in jedem restaurant weil das
heißt restaurant steht da natürlich ist
dann auch irgendwie nur eine
autobahnraststätte trotzdem ging das
echt gar nicht also die kartoffeln die
liegen da bestimmt schon fünf stunden
aufgewärmt die waren hart ich habe noch
nie so hart kartoffeln gestern also das
waren bratkartoffeln ihr habt ja gesehen
das kann man vom äußeren jetzt nicht
erkennen aber das war wirklich schlecht
hat mit dem getränk also ich hatte null
330 gekostet meine ich irgendwie so also
segafredo raststätten damals noch mal
das logo will ich euch nicht empfehlen
also wie so ein laden läuft keiner gut
ich war jetzt weiter und morgen früh
geht es dann zum frühstück da hat es
dann noch einen anderen rastplatz aus da
gucken was da zum frühstück da bin ich
auf jeden fall schon sehr gespannt
darauf freue mich auch und ich hoffe ich
kriege noch ein gutes frühstück bei base
oder wie auch immer man die leute was
geht
schönen guten morgen ich bin schon
unterwegs wir haben jetzt vier von neun
und ich bin auch schon auf dem rastplatz
ich wollte das jetzt nicht film weil es
ja irgendwie immer langweilig wir sind
jetzt hier auf jeden fall genau auf der
anderen seite wie gestern dass da hinten
war gestern
und hier gibt es einen segway ich frage
mich jetzt mittlerweile um ehrlich zu
sein ob das einfach eine tankstelle ist
weil dieses zeichen an der tankstelle
ich hoffe auch so ein schönes rührei
oder so mit brötchen habe ich noch nie
auf der autobahnraststätte gegessen
wir werden sehen
also hier haben wir auf jeden fall
macdonald und da ist ja jetzt auch sehr
weiß und segafredo gibt es auch aber da
will ich nicht hin
[Musik]
so leute fischer kam war einmal mehr ein
getränk zu fuß daneben sorgen
aprikosen cafe cappuccino und käse hier
ja ganz gut aus real gab es leider nicht
aber so ist es
[Musik]
so leute aufgegessen kosten habe ich mir
noch mitgenommen weil ich habe ein
bisschen angst dass mein auto
abgeschleppt wird
ich bin nämlich voll falsch bei den lkws
und genau da ist polizei und da steht
mein auto erwarte ich sehe gerade direkt
da ist eine polizeistation also
irgendwie schon echt um natürlich wird
es wahrscheinlich nicht abgeschleppt
aber weiß nicht ob man hier so ein
knöllchen kriegen kann
leute das frühstück war ganz okay gut
hat er über zwölf euro kostet finde ich
schon echt viel für so was auch noch
sagen dass musik hat auch vier euro
gekostet glaub ich deswegen sind wir
dann eher bei 8 aber es ist trotzdem
teuer
wir fahren jetzt erst mal nach hause und
dann gibt's dement fazit eine kleine
zusammenfassung und jetzt gucken
polizisten ich fahr mal schnell also
leute seht ihr da ist die polizeistation
und ich habe genau davor falsch geparkt
gut ich weiß nicht ob man dafür bestraft
werden kann
ja ich denke schon wenn die langeweile
haben ich bin mir meiner sache wollte
ich noch schnell aufnehmen und zwar gebt
euch mal
von hier kann man perfekt so die skyline
von köln sind wir auf jeden fall nice
aus jetzt vielleicht schon wieder dumm
so weit
ja ich bin wieder zu hause beim
challenge ist vorbei ich weiß ja wie es
ist eben schon gesagt hab aber das hat
mich jetzt an dem rastplatz doch mal
mehr verwirrt also ich hab ja wieder
dort gegessen und das essen war von
diesem diesem restaurant wo ich auch
dann schon davor am mittag war also das
erstes und die leute hatten surveys
kleidung an
also ich checks wirklich nicht wenn ihr
euch da raus gehen schreibt mir das sehr
gern den kommentar ich habe auch
gegoogelt dafür nicht auch nichts würde
ich mich drüber freuen sowie rechte mal
kurz zusammen was ich bezahlt habt für
alles also wir haben ja drei mahlzeiten
das ist auf jeden fall rekord von allen
challenges wir haben für das mittagessen
gestern 10 eur 73 +1 56 professional
wirklich vollkatastrophe die kartoffeln
waren steinhart das brötchen oder
steinhart also irgendwie am standort
menü
es war dass das war genau eine wurst im
brötchen es sich eigentlich sonst nicht
aber um das frühstück heute morgen 12
eur 34 honig konfitüre
das waren weil sie nicht wahr dass 15
gramm maximal 80 cent also hier steht
der endbetrag so viel habe ich bezahlt
jetzt rechnen wir eben noch die kalorien
aus ich brauche pro tag habe ich auch
noch aus jährigen ungefähr 2200 hallo
leute kalorien habe ich kann ungefähr
mal ausgerechnet ich komme auf 2.085
schon um mit betracht darauf dass sich
ja gestern abend das nicht ganz
vergessen habe ich würde mal sagen so
ein drittel waren noch übrig vielleicht
sogar die hälfte keine ahnung es war
echt nicht gut also das ist eigentlich
voll normal
dann würde ich sagen das war es auch
schon mit der challenge schreibt mir
super gerne eine neue challenge in die
kommentare für nächste woche
und mir hat mal wieder spaß gemacht ich
glaube sonst hätte ich nie in meinem
leben raststätten essen probiert also
abonniert für weitere challenge es gibt
noch nach oben kommentiert und jack and
install ab da ist sich alex w
wir sehen uns morgen wieder gibt's neues
video morgen gibt es auch wieder was mit
essen bin ich auch sehr gespannt drauf
das war hart rein